bonjour vous regardez et maintenant
l'émission qui revient avec plaisir et
avec vous sur l'actualité politique de
la semaine vous connaissez le principe
hashtag et maintenant si vous souhaitez
réagir sur ce plateau aujourd'hui on
accueille la crème de la crème ils ont
l'oeil vif et le cuir tanné ils n'ont
pas peur du débat Sophie de Ravinel
bonjour merci de revenir avec nous vous
êtes journaliste politique à côté de
vous Charles Consigny bonjour et c'est
avocat on a le plaisir d'accueillir
également Alexandra schwarzbroad bonjour
vous êtes directrice adjoint de la
rédaction de Libération romancière vous
avez écrit des lumières de Tel-Aviv aux
éditions rivages et le grand Georges
Marc Benhamou était aussi sur ce plateau
bonjour bonjour Jean-Marc vous tournez
actuellement une série inspirée du roman
La Peste d'Albert camion pour avoir 5
ans l'année prochaine si tout va bien on
va s'y réaliser par Antoine garsaud avec
le héros de en-thérapie notamment
Frédéric Pierrot on suivra ça dans cette
émission on célébrera plusieurs
anniversaires les amis oui le
périphérique parisien faite cette
semaine c'est 50 ans félicitations
on se demandera si c'est meilleures
années sont derrière lui alors can
Hidalgo souhaite le transformer le
mariage pour tous fait quant à lui ses
10 ans félicitations également on se
demandera s'il a définitivement eu
raison de ses meilleurs ennemis et puis
et puis Joe byden a quant à lui 80 ans
il est de nouveau candidat à la Maison
Blanche on se demandera si tout cela et
bien raisonnable merci président Larcher
mais d'abord un autre anniversaire
décidément souvenez-vous c'était il y a
tout juste un an regardez
je sais aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
et je veux ici
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote m'oblige pour les
années à venir
dès à présent
je ne suis plus le candidat d'un camp
mais le président de toutes et tous
Sophie un an après la réaction
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il faut
parler de démarrage raté en tout cas
d'anniversaire bien raté ou disons
d'anniversaire compliqué la première
année évidemment c'était c'était son
ça devait être la continuité de son
premier mandat on se posait tous la
question de ce que ça allait donner
c'est assez rare chez nous d'avoir un
comme ça un deuxième mandat et et de
fait il a été immédiatement saisi par
les complications et ça ne s'est jamais
arrêté et dans une succession un peu
comparable à ce qui s'est passé dans le
premier mandat et donc de cette façon là
on peut parler de poursuites et là je
quand on discute avec son entourage il
nous disent tous au sein du gouvernement
ou dans son cabinet finalement cette
épreuve de des retraites ça n'est que la
continuité du premier mandat mais là ça
va se terminer et en fait c'est la fin
et là on va enfin rentrer dans le
deuxième mandat mais ça fait quand même
un an qu'il essaie d'y rentrer
ah non pour rien je ne sais pas puisque
cette réforme des retraites si contestée
soit-elle elle est faite maintenant donc
s'il ne la retire pas et je pense pas
qu'il la retirera il aura au moins fait
ça qu'il n'avait pas fait pendant son
premier quinquennat moi ce que je pense
surtout c'est que Emmanuel Macron paie
un peu le l'ambiguïté en fait de son de
son projet
c'est un peu court de dire on va mettre
autour de la table les gens raisonnables
et bien intentionnés et on va essayer de
faire ensemble ce qui est le mieux pour
le pays on voit bien que au fond ça ça a
tenu quelques temps mais que les vieux
clivages reprennent le dessus et
particulièrement je trouve à l'occasion
de cette réforme des retraites moi il me
semble que quand même le clivage entre
la droite et la gauche a repris des
couleurs puisque la droite était plutôt
favorable à cette réforme à part
quelques quelques échappés solitaires
qui à mon avis était assez intéressé et
de l'autre côté c'est une gauche presque
à cette chaîne qui est qui qui a refait
surface avec des syndicats forts des
contestations dans la rue et ce genre de
choses donc moi je crois que les
Français en ont un peu marre qu'on
essaie de leur faire croire que
les choses ne sont pas idéologisées et
ne servent pas tel ou telle catégorie de
la population ils veulent qu'on leur
dise un peu la vérité et ils se rendent
compte qu'une part une partie du
macronisme repose sur une forme de
mensonge Alexandra sur peut-être sur le
bilan vraiment j'aimerais vraiment qu'on
s'intéresse cette première année vous
êtes d'accord avec Charles non
moi j'ai surtout été frappé par deux
passages du discours que vous venez de
diffuser ce bateau ce vote m'oblige ce
vote m'oblige donc on aurait pu penser
qu'il avait compris ce jour-là que il
avait été élu
aussi beaucoup notamment par la gauche
qui avait voulu faire barrage à Marine
Le Pen et non pas pour et non pas voté
pour lui Emmanuel Macron sa
manifestement il ne l'a pas compris
deuxième chose quand il dit et ça
rejoint quand il dit je vais maintenant
il faut tout faire pour lutter contre
l'extrême droite depuis un an depuis
depuis qu'il a été réélu l'extrême
droite n'a jamais été aussi
en force enfin en pointe et et ça c'est
et ça c'est très grave donc
pour moi sa première année est un échec
total mais total total et ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine avec les 100 jours
détaillés par Elizabeth borne montre
bien l'impuissance l'état d'impuissance
dans lequel se trouve aujourd'hui
l'exécutif un an après on va y revenir
George Michael vous avez connu un
certain François Mitterrand cette
première année d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
quoi c'est une des premières années les
plus laborieuses
de 15 des derniers quinquennat peut-être
on arrive à un état et parlons c'est pas
mal de le dire ou la Cinquième
République c'est bloquée elle a été
écrite par De Gaulle et Michel Debré
avec des équilibres très subtils elle a
été customisée de manière un peu
fantaisiste par Chirac et Jospin qu'ils
l'ont étouffé en inventant le
quinquennat d'athique etc et Macron
hérite d'un système totalement bloqué
François Mitterrand vous évoquez il a
répondu à ses institutions avec la
cohabitation bizarrement les Français
aimaient bien ça respirait pouvait aimer
ou pas là on est rentré dans un
troisième dans les cas de figure
majorité uniformes cohabitation dans un
cas de figure le blocage le blocage des
institutions et en fait on paye ça alors
moi je me souviens avoir abordé un
ministre éminent du gouvernement quand
ils avaient décidé souvenez-vous c'était
il y a ils avaient décidé deux mois de
délai entre l'élection et les
législatives vous êtes ça va pas en fait
et quelqu'un m'a répondu avec l'aplomb
des technocrates et des maoïstes que
c'était bien pensé qu'ils auraient une
majorité etc avec le même aplomb où on a
on explique qu'on nous explique il faut
surtout pas parler avec le CFDT etc donc
il y a quelque chose qui s'est passé on
arrive au point d'aboutissement d'une
crise d'un blocage des inscriptions on a
essayé de ruser aujourd'hui on sait pas
ce qu'il y a pas de majorité trop sévère
avec Emmanuel Macron
parce que Madame borne ne survivra pas
soit invention d'une nouvelle majorité
d'un changement que je vais vous montrer
quelques chiffres les chiffres notamment
du chômage actuellement en France ce
chômage est à
7,2 % c'était au quatrième trimestre de
l'année dernière un tel niveau n'avait
pas été connu depuis 2008 et en même
temps je vais vous montrer ce sondage se
baromètre réalisé par nos partenaires de
voxa Emmanuel Macron reste scotché à son
plus bas niveau de popularité soit 70%
des Français jugent qu'il est un mauvais
président est-ce qu'il y a pas là un
paradoxe Sophie un paradoxe où je dirais
une illustration d'une défiance
croissante des Français vis-à-vis de
l'action politique comme si elle était
déconnectée des résultats économiques et
on le voit bien avec Emmanuel Macron on
l'a vu avec François Hollande avant
est-ce que l'action de François Hollande
en matière économique était si mauvaise
que ça elle a été beaucoup critiquée
est-ce que ce qu'il a dit sur l'Ukraine
et la Russie n'était finalement pas plus
juste que ce qu'on peut dire d'autres
personnes avec lui avant lui et est-ce
que pour autant les Français lui ont
rendu
la enfin je veux dire est-ce qu'ils ont
été juste dans leur jugement vis-à-vis
des politiques c'est pareil d'une
certaine façon pour Emmanuel Macron
parce que je le disais tout à l'heure il
aussi le fruit de de ce qui lui vient de
l'extérieur et dont il n'est pas
responsable est-ce qu'il est responsable
de la crise en Ukraine il était
responsable des mots qu'il dit sur la
Russie est-ce qu'il est responsable de
la crise en Indo-Pacifique il était
responsable de la façon dont il parle à
Taïwan et aux États-Unis mais enfin
cette même pas de sa seule
responsabilité sinon ça le saurait si la
France était vraiment la puissance que
qu'elle a pu être mais donc je trouve
effectivement les Français ne même si
les résultats aussi bons vont-ils
continuer à être je crains qu'il
continueront à tenir rigueur de ce que
les politiques ne parviennent pas et
sans doute parce que nous sommes dans
une crise institutionnelle ne
parviennent pas à les rassurer sur leur
avenir et sur les institutions George
Marc les Français ne sont pas assez
reconnaissants au président Macron non
il y a quelque chose qui s'est déréglé
Mitterrand l'a lancé en disant je suis
le dernier des présidents mais les
centres quelque chose
qui s'est déréglé peut-être avec la
construction européenne le rapport
timide compliqué des chefs avec les
Français enfin Sarkozy paraît élu par
élu Hollande qui n'arrive pas à se
représenter
Macron qui réussit exploit de se faire
non pas réélire mais reconduire donc
cette espèce de frustration de de
d'image donc il y a quelque chose entre
les Français et leurs chefs qui ne
fonctionnent pas peut-être cette
verticalité ce manque de respiration
enfin il y a là il y a un vrai et puis
un peuple un gouvernable en fait je veux
dire depuis Jules César de Gaulle enfin
on a vu la difficulté de gouverner les
Français donc c'est un rapport
particulier au pouvoir aux réformes et
au sens des réformes ou veut aller
Macron Alexandre sur quoi justement un
président donc avant on regardait
beaucoup les chiffres du chômage les
chiffres de l'emploi aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui fait que Emmanuel Macron
ou un autre d'ailleurs serait un bon
président mais c'est un ensemble c'est
un ensemble c'est pas sur un point ou
sur un autre sur les chiffres du chômage
c'est vrai qu'ils sont pas mauvais je
pense qu'Emmanuel Macron on l'a
bénéficié de la sortie du covid et du
confinement ou l'économie est reparti à
fond la caisse
regarde et ça c'est un rapport avec la
réforme des retraites si on regarde bien
les chiffres les les chiffres du chômage
des 50 ans et plus ne se sont pas
améliorés du tout et c'est là où on voit
qu'il y a un petit problème avec la
réforme des retraites justement avec
l'allongement
la question des seniors
mais il a pas été bon du tout Emmanuel
Macron et c'est ça que les que les les
gens retiennent cette ce projet de rêve
cette réforme des retraites n'était ni
faite ni à faire et et elle a pas été
pensée elle a été faite sur un point de
table parce qu'il voulait vite que cette
réforme passe au tout début de son
nouveau quinquennat mais elle elle a été
mal communiqué enfin tout a été mauvais
et en plus Emmanuel Macron a réussi
cette prouesse se fâcher avec le
syndicat réformiste qu'il avait avec lui
la CFDT leur envergers qu'il avait avec
lui lors de son premier projet de
réforme des retraites voilà pour le chef
de l'État Charles vous d'accord avec ça
aujourd'hui ce que dit un peu Alexandra
c'est que finalement on est focalisé sur
cette réforme des retraites et ça c'est
un peu ça ça on parle que de ça on pense
qu'à ça on regarde pas d'autres
indicateurs les navigateurs que je viens
de montrer notamment sur la cour du
chômage et qui est plutôt bonne oui
alors Emmanuel Macron est décrit par
exemple par Jean-Pierre Levade qui est
pas qui est pas l'idiot du village comme
quelqu'un qui n'est pas sérieux il dit
ça n'est pas un homme de sérieux il
s'inquiète notamment d'un déni de
réalité chez Emmanuel Macron en
particulier sur les finances publiques
qui sont selon perleva des de la vie
générale dans une situation quand même
très inquiétante et sur l'attractivité
du pays puisque par le va de relève que
la balance des paiements est encore très
déficitaire et que donc en fait on n'est
pas devenu si attractif que ça et c'est
vrai que il suffit de voyager un peu
pour voir qu'en France c'est pas
exactement le hotspot international où
tout le monde s'ins pour créer des
startups et implanter des usines dans
des plaises à la communication
gouvernementale donc je pense que il a
une légèreté qui fait qu'en fait il
voudrait croire à tout ça il voudrait
penser qu'il fait avancer le pays etc
mais moi je commence à être assez vieux
pour me souvenir de période précédente
de manière assez distincte et j'ai quand
même le un sentiment fort de
déclassement du pays quand on voit on a
vu l'état de nos hôpitaux pendant le
covid c'est la faute d'Emmanuel Macron
mais ça fait quand même 5 ans qu'il est
Président il était avant ministre de
l'économie il a été secrétaire général
adjoint de l'Élysée ça fait quand même
un petit moment que lui ou les gens
autour de lui sont aux manettes moi je
constate que l'hôpital va très mal je
vis tous les jours la justice comme
avocat la justice c'est hallucinant on a
à peu près la justice moldave enfin
c'est quand même un truc très il faut le
voir de près les délais d'audiencement
l'état des bureaux ont été débloqués on
va pas rentrer sur ce sujet en
particulier
les services publics sont dans un état
lamentable et moi ce que je constate en
gros c'est que au fond le macronisme ne
profite comme acronismes c'est-à-dire si
vous êtes cadre supérieur dans un grand
entreprises du CAC 40 que vous habitez
dans un coin agréable et que vous avez
une maison de campagne vous avez passé
votre covid là vous êtes content de
Macron parce qu'il a baissé vos impôts
tout va bien pour vos enfants etc mais
en dehors de cette catégorie là je moi
je vois pas en quoi la politique
actuelle de ce gouvernement augmente les
bas salaire améliore les services
publics des gens pauvres améliore les
transports publics règle la question de
l'insécurité tout ça je vois pas de
changement ni d'amélioration faut-il
avoir peur des casseroles depuis la
promulgation de la réforme des retraites
la contestation ne faiblit pas les
déplacements des ministres
sont perturbés par des concerts de
casseroles comme sur ces images que vous
voyez de la gare de Lyon lundi ou un
comité d'accueil attendait le ministre
de l'éducation nationale Papé Ndiaye
quelques instants plus tard il a tout
simplement dû être exciltré de la gare
par son service de sécurité regardez
démissionnez ayez la dignité de
démissionner
s'il vous plaît faites quelque chose
pour les années sages donnez-leur un
vrai statut
c'est honteux
[Musique]
Alexandra est-ce qu'on est en train de
passer un cap dans la colère sociale
pour l'instant non pour l'instant il y a
juste une colère qui s'exprime mais qui
est à la hauteur du sentiment de de
d'ignorance qui qui s'isolait les
Français ont une impression d'être
totalement ignorée pas entendu d'où les
casseroles voilà c'est tout pour
l'instant c'est tout si ça continue
comme ça un ministre qui a empêché de
sortir de la gare de Lyon mais je vous
dis c'est la hauteur de la colère donc
ce qui serait inquiétant c'est si ça
continue je pense que ça va continuer
sur jusqu'au 1er mai les manifestations
massives du 1er mai peut-être un peu
jusqu'à l'été a priori et après on
devrait passer dans une autre phase la
vie politique et la vie tout court la
vie internationale s'il y a une
contre-offensive en
Ukraine je pense que ça va balayer aussi
pas mal de d'autres d'autres sujets
politiques donc je pour l'instant non je
pense que ce n'est pas c'est pas un déni
Sophie vous voyez aussi de la colère
légitime alors vous regardez ces images
là de la gare de Lyon face à nous non en
tout cas fraîchement revendiqué moi je
serai juste
un peu en décalage par rapport à vous
parce que j'ai le sentiment en tout cas
c'est du côté politique et syndical ce
qu'on me dit c'est que ça va être très
fort au moins jusqu'au 14 juillet parce
que on parlait du produit absolument on
parlait du 1er mai aujourd'hui je
discutais hier avec un député insoumis
ils sont vraiment au manœuvres pour
faire en sorte que le 14 juillet soit
une très grosse fête de la Révolution
française et les syndicats semblent
certains en tout cas peut-être pas les
réformistes mais en tout cas les autres
la CGT sudrive évidemment on est faux
très en force pour faire du 14 juillet
un moment de rupture évidemment dans la
tradition révolutionnaire française on
ne sait pas jusqu'où ils vont aller mais
ce que je sais c'est que certains
discutent déjà de coupure de courant
pour Cannes de perturbations du jeu
évidemment pendant Roland Garros de la
fête de musique de la fête de la musique
comme une casserole à géante et tout ça
ça vous paraît légitime ou est-ce que là
on assiste prog une dérive je dirais un
peu populiste je dirais que c'est alors
là encore j'ai pas de réponse à la
question parce que ce serait porté un
jugement politique mais en revanche ce
que je pense c'est qu'il y a une
évolution du type de mobilisation
sociale c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu ce
moment des syndicats avec toutes ces
marches 12 moi j'étais au 12 mars et
c'était quand même très impressionnant
je évidemment il n'y a pas eu dans la
France tous ces blocages les blocages
RATP les blocages SNCF le blocage de
transport finalement il n'a pas eu tant
que ça il y avait déjà eu beaucoup de
discussions avec mais il y a eu toutes
ces grands tous ces grandes
manifestations là on est vraiment sur
quelque chose de différent qui se veut à
la fois une colère profonde et festif et
c'est cette espèce de mélange de fait et
de colère qui est assez nouveau et qui
selon moi pourrait bien prendre aussi
l'été non seulement pendant les
festivals de musique de culture etc mais
aussi en raison de ce qui nous attend et
c'est mon dernier mot sur les pics de
chaleur de sécheresse avec une colère
sociale qui risque d'être très forte
Olivier du sable justement on a
interrogé sur ces casseroles et
peut-être ce qu'il en pense
qui sont ces quelques dizaines de
personnes qui ici ou là se posent un
senseur vont décider de qui a le droit
de venir sur l'espace public ont décidé
que des députés élus réélu dans leur
circonscription ne pourraient pas
prendre la parole c'est une drôle de
conception de la démocratie donc nous
allons continuer à aller sur le terrain
manifester
ça fait partie de la démocratie vouloir
en découdre ça ne fait pas partie de la
démocratie non vouloir menacer des des
élus des députés vouloir menacer des
membres du gouvernement ça n'est pas la
démocratie
ne pensent pas comme vous ça n'est pas
la démocratie George Marc vous êtes
d'accord il y a un notre démocratie est
aujourd'hui menacée ton danger
ça va pas le climat et pas très bien les
institutions marchent pas ça agrippe etc
non c'est pas le c'est pas la révolution
mais c'est pas on peut pas dire on peut
pas dire aux gens de sortir avec il y a
un côté sous-préfet aux champs le mec il
écrit on va interdire les commentaires
c'est un peu ridicule et en même temps
on voit bien soyons pas naïf qui a une
technique de harcèlement militant et
numérique militants et numérique
c'est-à-dire c'est facile sur des
applications WhatsApp etc et ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est un passage relatifs syndicat à une
société civile de gauche d'extrême
gauche attaque certains mouvements
écologistes etc c'est facile en effet de
donner rendez-vous au Festival de Cannes
on peut vous annoncer qui va se passer
des choses en effet au Festival
d'Avignon peut-être un peu moins parce
que etc à Roland-Garros ou les riches
vont se réunir etc donc comme on peut
plus bloquer en fait la CGT n'a plus le
pouvoir de bloquer les transports ou
l'énergie c'est un fait nouveau donc de
nouvelles actions sont en train de
s'inventer dans la lutte sociale on peut
pas dire non plus c'est pas non plus
d'une grande santé démocratique mais
c'est aussi dû à mon avis et une sorte
de d'étouffement démocratique dont je
parlais tout à l'heure je suis assez
content qu'on revienne peut-être à
l'ancien monde la société française a
peut-être besoin de respirer avec une
gauche et une droite qui s'engueule
plutôt que d'avoir que des extrémistes
la société française elle a peut-être
besoin de parler avec ses corps
intermédiaires alors que le macronisme a
théorisé qu'il avait pas besoin de ses
corps intermédiaires donc c'est toute la
respiration démocratique de cette
cinquième république je vais vous poser
la question mettre Consigny avec ses
préfets justement qui voilà qui
multiplient les arrêtés pour interdire
les casseroles pour aussi interdire les
rassemblements festifs parce que on
assiste de l'autre côté aussi à une
sorte de dérive du pouvoir qui a
peut-être un peu peur de ces
manifestations devant Emmanuel Macron
devant certains ministres alors pour moi
la dérive elle antérieur là leurs
arrêtés qui se font retoquer des heures
systématiques
administrative d'ailleurs il y a une
espèce de jeu il est publié plus tard
possible pour être attaqué pour être
censuré par le juge administratif après
la visite du ministre du président bon
scepti arrêté moi ça me choque pas
particulièrement en tant que juriste ou
même comme citoyen beaucoup moins que
les tirs de LBD40 dans les yeux des
manifestants si vous voulez ça ça me
choque et l'absence de suite judiciaire
pour les auteurs de s'étirent ça ça me
choque beaucoup plus en termes de
raidissement de même le dévoiement de
disposition législatives légales prévues
pour le terrorisme qu'on qu'on exploite
après pour pour essayer de réprimer la
contestation sociale mais justement moi
j'ai une sentiment quand même
si vous voulez c'est comme une
cocotte-minute en ce moment qui explose
c'est à dire que on a été sous cloche
pendant 5 ans on n'avait pas vraiment le
droit de contester
il y a eu les gilets jaunes si on était
souvenez-vous le gouvernement très vite
à traiter les gilets jaunes d'antisémite
de fascisme de beaufs sous le c'est il
le disait pas comme ça mais enfin on
comprenait et là en fait c'est la
vengeance
ensuite pendant le covid vous n'aviez
pas le droit de remettre quoi que ce
soit en question alors qu'on nous
imposait quand même des mesures les plus
liberticides probablement depuis la
guerre mais si vous posiez la moindre
question vous étiez un demeurer
complotiste pro Raoul antivac etc et de
la même façon d'une façon générale le
macronisme comme il se veut le parti
central des gens raisonnables de droite
et de gauche qui œuvrent pour le bien
commun si vous étiez contre eux vous
étiez forcément un extrême que ce soit
l'extrême gauche ou l'extrême ou alors
un ringard si vous restiez à droite
comme ça peut être mon cas et ben je
pense que les Françaises sont moins
idiots que ce que pensent ces ministres
qui payent aussi leur arrogance cette
famille politique qui paye aussi son
arrogance et c'est ça qui se prennent
actuellement c'est les gens qui disent
maintenant arrêtez de nous prendre pour
des cons et laissez-nous être
intelligent Alexandra c'est une
cocotte-minute qui explose le madison
actuellement non mais c'est très
intéressant tout ce qui vient d'être dit
c'est que en fait c'est plus encore que
l'échec d'Emmanuel Macron c'est l'échec
du macronisme auquel on est en train
d'assister c'est vraiment ça ne
fonctionne plus le en même temps ça ne
peut pas fonctionner c'est c'est on voit
bien et donc et pourtant voilà il va
falloir tenir encore quatre ans donc ça
paraît très très compliqué parce qu'on
voit bien à la fois entre les
institutions qui sont bloquées cet homme
qui ne fait plus rêver si tenter qu'il
en est fait rêver certains mais il en a
peut-être fait sur notamment toute cette
partie de la gauche
qu'il a intéressé pour son côté très
européen parce que ça c'était quelque
chose et son et puis ces idées
internationales et on voit bien que même
là dessus même là-dessus sur internet le
nombre de bêtises qu'il a qui l'a fait
ces derniers ces derniers temps la
dernière en date étant celle de de sur
le Taïwan qui était quand même une
énorme
chinois s'intéresse à l'Ukraine
peut-être que il faudra revoir les
dossiers il y a peut-être
anniversaire les amis il y a 10 ans le
Parlement adopté loi autorisant le
mariage au couple homosexuel une mesure
qui à l'époque avait provoqué une très
forte opposition dans une partie de la
société française d'emmener notamment
par la manif pour tous et puis et puis
certains ont changé d'avis avec le temps
prenez par exemple Gérald Darmanin il
déclarait à l'époque ne pas vouloir
célébrer personnellement ces unions en
tant que mère de Tourcoing aujourd'hui
il rétro
je suis conseiller municipal c'est un
couple gay souhaite que je les Marie je
le ferai bien volontiers comme tout
couple je pense que c'était une erreur
de ma part de voter contre le mariage
pour tous c'est bien d'abord que les
hommes politiques reconnaissent en
erreur je me suis trompé je le reconnais
évidemment si j'ai décédé Jean et j'ai
eu sans doute des propos pour PC des
gens là je pense que c'est pas le rôle
d'un homme politique de le faire et
c'était aucunement mon envie et par
ailleurs je crois que la gauche à ce
moment-là le Parti socialiste le
président Hollande en particulier a eu
raison Charles vous voyez un Volt fasse
sincère ou une stratégie politique alors
Gérald Darmanin il y a aussi Valérie
Pécresse que vous connaissez bien qui
était contre à l'époque et qui
maintenant sont pour ce qui était
amusant c'est qu'il dit lui-même c'est
bien que les hommes politiques
reconnaissent leurs erreurs c'est génial
il dit un truc et il s'auto attribue le
bon point lié à ce qui est ce qu'il faut
être gêner
quelque chose puis juste après je dis
c'est intéressant ce que je viens de
dire oui je trouve ça c'est assez
phénoménal non malheureusement je crois
que ce que ça traduit au fond je pense
qu'à fois qu'il n'était pas au fond de
même Darmanin Pécresse
si vous savez c'est Philippe muret qui
disait sans arrière-pensée mais sans
penser devant non plus donc si tentait
qu'ils aient pu avoir une pensée au fond
de même je ne pense pas que ils étaient
contre le mariage pour tous je pense que
j'espère en tout cas pour eux que ils
étaient en réalité ils voyaient aucune
objection mais qui se disait que
politiquement il fallait qu'ils adoptent
cette position donc malheureusement ça
ça jette un peu le discrédit sur ce
qu'ils peuvent dire par ailleurs moi je
préfère il y en a peu mais les hommes et
les femmes politiques qui pratiquent une
politique de l'offre c'est-à-dire ils
disent qu'ils pensent malgré tout
Sarkozy est un peu comme ça ça a pu lui
être reproché sur certains sujets ils
disent qu'ils pensent et ça match ou ça
marche pas avec la population c'est plus
l'impression qu'il se cale sur ce qui
croyait bon pour eux politique
cette semaine c'était la repentance
c'était le défi de si on est obligé
monsieur Béchu comment il s'appelle le
ministre d'écologie voilà Monsieur ah
lui mais Darmanin ça a été le plus malin
c'est le premier ensuite elle repentance
madame Pécresse monsieur be je suis
d'ailleurs deux trois macronistes qu'on
a oublié il manque Christine
elle tient bon mais je suis sûr que les
macronistes de droite tout le monde a
fait sa repentance c'est quelque chose
de grotesque en effet il croit il
croyait pas avant je te caution et je
pense qu'il pense il pense pas plus
aujourd'hui
sur la question
c'est ridicule est-ce qu'il faut
peut-être s'en féliciter voilà c'est
déjà s'il n'y a plus de débat sur cette
question je pense qu'il y a même plus de
débats il y a pas l'ombre d'un débat
maintenant c'est une nuit quelque chose
dont on ne discute même plus et ça c'est
formidable mais ça fait quand même mal
au cœur quand on pense à tous les
tomberont d'injures que ce sont pris
François Hollande Christiane Taubira
enfin tous ceux qui ont porté cette
réforme toutes les injures qui se sont
pris dans la figure et entendre dix ans
plus tard ce moment là finalement
c'était bien d'avoir fait ça bon c'est
ça fait quand même mal au
coeurs
et pour beaucoup d'autres choses ça fait
que ça vaudra pour la suite pour la loi
sur la fin de vie sur l'euthanasie mais
sur Gérald Darmanin pour y revenir une
seconde moi ce que j'ai surtout entendu
c'est une déclaration de candidature
enfin ça c'était évident alors après
politique évidemment comme tout le monde
mais pour Matignon en l'occurrence lui
et du coup il était obligé de se laver
de se retirer son vêtement d'un famille
qui data dit il y a 10 ans il a choisi
le bon moment il a été le premier
toujours plus malin que les autres on
parlait de Sarkozy qui disait de lui
qu'il était le meilleur d'entre eux
voilà et donc il a il a fait ça
que la société française aussi a changé
et du coup Gérald Darmanin il suit un
peu la société française l'opinion
publique oui mais évidemment parce que
l'opinion publique a vu que cette
affaire là voilà et je pense que
certains ceux qui sont restés sur leur
conviction vous parliez à droite moi je
pense à François-Xavier Bellamy ou à
d'autres qui a été tête de liste aux
Européennes et qui a mais qui et qui
sont sur leur position qui n'en ont pas
bougé ça en doute un des rares qui
doivent avoir ce type de conduction de
façon ferme à droite et cela reste
convaincu que ce n'est pas un bien pour
la famille des autres la société
française le sondage
on va voir cette photo publiée sur
Twitter par le député européen Nicolas
Bay 10 ans après toujours contre il
accompagné de Marion maréchal et du
sénateur Stéphane Ravier à qui s'adresse
ces élus quand il poste ce genre de
photo il s'adresse évidemment à ceux qui
veulent reconstruire la droite parce que
je me permets juste de prendre la parole
pour rebondir sur ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure chers Consigny sur le
fait que vous voyez la résurgence de la
droite et de la gauche moi que je vois
c'est toujours si je peux me permettre
la tripartition entre disons de
populisme fort et une gauche et une
droite qui reste quand même très très
faible et ce macronisme dont on peut se
poser la question de savoir s'il est une
forme de populisme aussi dans la mesure
où il est dirigé par une personne seule
qui n'a pas vraiment de partie autour de
lui moi ce que je vois surtout c'est
effectivement un appel du pied à ceux
qui voudraient reconstituer ou
constituer cette droite nationaliste
avec Zemmour sans Zemmour avec le RN
avec Jordan mardella ou Marine Le Pen et
de l'autre côté un Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou
un François Ruffin qui bénéficie
finalement du même service qu'a rendu
Éric Zemmour à Marine Le Pen c'est à
dire qu'il il rend la personne il est en
bourgeoise la personne et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en bourgeoise François Ruffin
ça reste le même type d'extrémisme donc
on voit quand même qu'à la droite de la
droite il y a quand même certains qui
revendiquent encore certaines idées ses
idées c'est très identité
je ne le courant Bel-Ami c'est il place
en et pour reconstruire la droite ça
pourrait être un petit groupe de cette
droite à reconstruire mais c'est pas le
courant porteur de la droite qui peut
surfer sur le mariage pour tous etc et
bonheur Auteuil etc
en tout cas ça sent pas le non ça sent
pas la grande vague sociologique avec ce
que vous disiez Charles c'est aussi
peut-être une manière de dire bon ben
voilà moi je j'ai de la suite dans mes
idées avec Sandra est-ce qu'il faut pas
s'en féliciter voilà ils ont des idées
ils ont des convictions il est défend
jusqu'au bout enfin sans féliciter je
serais bien la dernière capacité au
contraire mais mais oui oui bien sûr il
est simplement pour l'instant pour
l'instant je suis pas sûr qu'il qui
représente la magie qui m'aime qu'ils
approchent de la majorité de la
population non pas du tout il représente
un petit groupe qui n'a que ça qui n'a
que ça sur lequel bâtir sa politique que
ce genre de sujet et je pense qu'ils
sont pas du tout du tout dans le coup
pour finir sur ce point Charles vous
dites merci à François en tout cas je
dis merci à Christiane Taubira parce que
je trouve qu'elle a par ailleurs très
bien porté cette réforme ça faisait
quand même du bien d'avoir une femme
politique à la tribune je me souviens
quand elle a cité Léon Gontran Damas
nous les peut nous les veut etc nous les
riens nous les chiens c'est un très beau
poème
ça faisait du bien d'avoir un peu de
lettres et de panache à l'Assemblée pour
porter ce texte donc c'était évidemment
une bonne réforme et d'ailleurs pour
répondre aussi sur Bel-Ami etc je pense
qu'ils sont non seulement décalés par
rapport à la majorité de la population
mais ça on a le droit après tout de
d'avoir des convictions minoritaires il
y a aucun problème là-dessus mais alors
je pense que dans les jeunes générations
ils sont particulièrement décalées parce
que moi qui parle avec tout le monde il
m'arrive aussi de parler avec des
militants de reconquête du RN etc ne
serait-ce que pour savoir ce qu'ils
pensent et pour essayer de les
convaincre de changer de d'avis
typiquement la question gale la question
du mariage pour tous elle est assez
réglée de de leur côté et
une droite nationaliste même reconquête
moi j'ai pas le je n'ai pas le sentiment
que c'est une question qui fait encore
tant que ça propose la progression de la
loi voilà donc c'est une question qui
est plus ou moins qui est plus ou moins
politiquement régler les amis le talent
n'attend pas le nombre d'années ce mardi
jobiden 80 ans a annoncé sa candidature
à la présidentielle de 2024 il l'a fait
dans un clic très américain regardez la
question à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés et de savoir si dans les
années à venir nous aurons plus ou moins
de liberté plus ou moins de droit je
sais ce que je veux comme réponse et je
pense que vous le savez aussi ce n'est
pas le moment de se reposer sur ses
lauriers c'est pourquoi je suis candidat
ma réélection si vous êtes d'accord avec
moi rendez-vous sur Joe biden.com et
inscrivez-vous finissons ce travail je
sais que nous pouvons le faire car il
s'agit des États-Unis d'Amérique il n'y
a rien tout simplement rien que nous ne
puissions faire si nous le faisons
ensemble s'il est réélu Jo Biden aura 86
ans à la fin de son mandat est-ce que
son âge est un problème Alexandra
oui et non oui et non ce que ça montre
cette candidature sur tous c'est que du
côté démocrate il y a pas beaucoup de il
y a pas beaucoup de renouvellement ça
montre aussi la faiblesse de kamalahari
parce que finalement quand elle a été
nommée la vice-présidente quand elle a
été nommée vice-président de beaucoup
espérait que ce serait celle qui
pourrait soit si Joe Biden était empêché
soit par la suite prendre le relais pour
l'instant pour l'instant personne enfin
elle ne perce pas
après Joe Biden bon c'est vrai que c'est
vrai qu'il a son âge c'est vrai qu'il
fait des bourdes c'est vrai qu'il
trébuche quand ils montent des escaliers
86 ans à la fin d'Amanda tout ce qui
peut éviter la réélection de Donald
Trump ou d'un run des Santis tout ce qui
pourra l'éviter sera bon à prendre je
pense que c'est ça c'est ça le pire et
je trouve que le bilan de Joe Biden
n'est pas si mauvais est-ce que
l'inverse c'est pas ce qui va se passer
parce qu'effectivement le jeu Biden qui
revient dans l'arène est-ce que il y a
pas un rejet aussi qui ferait que Donald
Trump reviendrait sur le devant de la
scène Charles qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez est-ce qu'on va réassister à ce
même duel Trump Biden est-ce que voilà
c'est un peu ennuyeux de revivre ce
match qu'on a déjà vécu moi je trouve à
Trump un talent phénoménal quand même je
trouve que par exemple sur sa
comparution en justice la manière dont
il a réussi à tourner cet événement à
son avantage je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'hommes politiques français mais en
examen qui aurait aimé avoir le même le
même talent je sais pas si la si la si
sa réélection est souhaitable sa fin de
mandat était quand même assez assez
cauchemardesque là je parle de Trump
mais en même temps je vais vous dire au
fond de moi je j'admire ces Américains
qui en vote entre Trump ont vraiment
opposé une fin de non-recevoir radicale
à toute forme de socialisme je parle en
présence de mes de mes amis de gauche
j'ai trouvé ça assez phénoménal qui
disent écoutez nous vos impôts votre
distribution votre walking tout ça merci
mais non
je trouvais ça voilà alors qu'en France
il y a quand même malgré tout une une
pénétration des idées de gauche un peu
un peu dans dans toutes les familles
politiques pour le meilleur et pour le
pire je dis pas mais je trouvais que ça
manquait pas de panache et pour vous
répondre oui moi je pense quand même
qu'il est trop vieux maintenant Biden
je vous donne la parole dans une seconde
George mal je vais vous montrer ces
réformes qui ont été enclenchées par Joe
Biden avec notamment un plan de relance
post covid de 1900 milliards pour
remettre l'America Flo un plan
d'infrastructure
1200 milliards la transition climatique
4 400 milliards sur 10 ans pour
développer les industries vertes la
création d'un impôt minimum de 15% sur
les bénéfices des grandes entreprises
bilan des quatre premières années de
Biden une économie qui en 2022 affiche
plus 2 % de croissance c'est un taux de
chômage historiquement bas à
3,7
le bilan est bon écoutez si on le
regarde il a l'air Kako mais il a l'air
des fois il se perdent dans le parc etc
mais quand on regarde le fond des choses
sa politique en fait il fait ce que
Macron aurait dû en France toute chose
étant égale par ailleurs non il fait une
politique sociale libérale créative avec
des éléments des paramètres extrêmement
solides et paramètres sur le climatique
sur des équipes jeunes autour de qui
sont assez modernes et au fond oublions
le vieil homme la politique de Biden
elle est à la fois très responsable sur
le plan international très américain et
très moderne moi je peux peut-être plus
intéressante que celle d'Obama qui était
un peu trop high society etc
deuxièmement le le la seule manière et
cela aussi Macron devrait tirer en tirer
des enseignements de survivre cette
pensée qu'on a un avenir sinon dans un
cadre élection on n'est plus obéi alors
se présentera-t-il une chiné tout comme
moi si j'étais son conseiller ah bah
Biden je lui ai dit oui annonce ta
candidature
la même manière Macron a des problèmes
et c'est le problème qu'on vit
aujourd'hui car il n'a pas de futur moi
je lui conseillerais de se représenter
en 2032 ou de ou de laisser croire si on
a pas de dire en politique en deuxième
mandat on est mort donc de tout point de
vue et enfin Biden face à Trump à 3 ans
près on a un fou populiste qui amène des
troupes sur son truc tu es bien tu es
bien gentil toi et cetera et on a un
démocrate à l'ancienne extrêmement
efficace et ouvert à une certaine
modernité bizarrement malgré son
apparence Sophie peu importe l'âge c'est
le bilan qui compte on a vu quelques
mesures quelques réformes plancher le
bilan était essentiel et puis surtout
les circonstances enfin je veux dire que
sont les circonstances
il y a une il est obligé d'une façon qui
peut d'autres y aller que lui à la
limite que je suppose les démocrates
doivent se dire même s'il est un pantin
même s'il n'est que l'ombre de lui-même
il faut qu'il soit là parce que de toute
façon ce n'est pas lui qui va gouverner
et on le sait bien enfin on le sait bien
on imagine que si il est trop fatigué il
peut y avoir quand même de bonnes façons
de de alors je ne dis pas qu'en
gouvernera à sa place mais enfin je veux
dire que il cherche bien des solutions
pour ça mais ce qui est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autre solution et c'est là
où moi je vois le drame c'est ce
vieillissement de la politique mais chez
eux je suis démocrate aucune figure qui
puisse faire face à Trump je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur le fait de dire
que bon bah on peut passer par perdre
tes profit le alors évidemment on peut
se féliciter du fait qu'il y ait un peu
une moine politiquement correcte mais
enfin à ce point là justement qui
réagissent à cette annonce de Joe by
dance après ok on va écouter les
Américains qui réagissent
j'apprécie ce que byden a fait je trouve
qu'il a fait du très bon travail
personnellement je souhaiterais qu'il ne
se représente pas j'ai 72 ans il est
plus âgé que moi et vraiment trop âgé
pour ce travail
s'il est en bonne santé et qu'il pense
qu'il peut faire le travail je trouve
que c'est parfaitement conv honnêtement
je préférerais que l'on donne une chance
à quelqu'un d'un peu plus jeune et qui a
des idées nouvelles pour le pays
je pense qu'il est trop vieux pour ce
représenter il est peut-être en bonne
santé aujourd'hui mais qui sait dans six
ans comment il ira je pense donc qu'il
est temps pour lui de se retirer et de
laisser la place à quelqu'un d'autre
Sophie
quand il a été élu sénateur du delawar
il y a 50 ans il se moquette son
adversaire en raison de son âge donc
voilà toujours se méfier de ses propos
le fait très rapidement un bilan sur la
scène internationale Alexandra de Joe
Biden bilan plutôt positif vous parlez
de Taïwan savait plutôt mal démarré avec
l'Afghanistan qui a laissé un qui a
laissé un grand grand vide et donc son
envie de se désengager de
l'international et de se concentrer sur
la scène américaine sa probablement
laissé justement les mains libres un
Vladimir machines qui s'est dit qu'il
pouvait faire ce qu'il voulait mais sur
la fin je trouve que sur la guerre en
Ukraine il a bien il a plutôt bien joué
Joe Biden non le bilan pas négatif les
relations entre la France et les
États-Unis Charles malheureusement les
États-Unis elle baptise de notre
affaiblissement malheureusement on est
bien obligé de constater que les
Américains n'ont plus la même
considération pour nous mais c'est pas
le fait des Américains c'est le fait de
du déplacement de de des puissances du
monde vers l'Asie et du reparamétrage
des forces mondiales moi je trouve je
reconnais à Biden de ne pas trembler
quand il s'agit de nommer les choses ou
quand il s'agit d'agir très tôt il s'est
exprimé sur Poutine en le traitant de
criminels je me souviens sur l'Ukraine
il n'hésite pas alors certains
évidemment prennent des arrières pensées
aux États-Unis en disant que de toute
façon ils cherchent toujours à affaiblir
ou détruire leurs ennemis historiques
donc en l'espèce la Russie après Trump
sur la scène internationale je suis
désolé de le dire mais il est allé en
Corée du Nord il a rencontré leader
nord-coréen
mais personne ne l'avait fait avant donc
c'était une première étage c'était quand
même une première étape et je trouve par
ailleurs que
avec la Chine Trump manifestait une
intransigence qui était à mon sens assez
bienvenu retour en France où on a marqué
cette semaine les 50 ans du périph
parisien il avait été inauguré sous
Georges Pompidou il sera peut-être
enterré ou en tout cas très transformé
par Anne Hidalgo écoutez le périph c'est
aussi 500 000 personnes qui vivent
autour et qui sont exposés justement à
ces deux pollutions très importantes qui
a un problème bien sûr de santé publique
il y a un problème de changement
climatique et d'adaptation de la ville à
ce changement climatique et donc oui il
faut transformer planifier c'est pas du
jour au lendemain bien sûr que la
question de la vitesse est un des sujets
je ne souhaite pas le trancher moi
directement mais il sera soumis
évidemment à la discussion on verra ce
que cette grande concertation qui va
s'ouvrir je m'engage je suis vrai et
j'accompagnerai la ligne réalisée en
juin de l'année dernière année d'algo
qui veut limiter la vitesse à 50 km/h
sur le périph et supprimer une voix pour
la réserver au covoiturage et au
transport collectif le but c'est de
diminuer le nombre de véhicules utilisés
pour se déplacer georgema qu'est-ce que
c'est une bonne initiative
l'Afrique question moi je me souviens
d'avoir une conversation ça vous permet
de bizarre avec l'ancien maire de Paris
qui m'a expliqué
non non avec Monsieur tibery qu'on moque
beaucoup c'est le premier qui m'a
expliqué le massacre qui
a constitué le périphérique est une
vraie cicatrice qui a séparé des
territoires c'est à dire que
Gennevilliers le 14e ou c'était c'était
la même ville etc enfin il y avait une
continuité il y a une sorte de grande
blessure
à réparer et je suis pas sûr que sur le
covoiturage façon façon madame delco la
vraie question c'est la couverture du
périph probablement c'est réparé comment
on dit réparer les vivants réparer le
corps de Paris et refaire cette
passerelle avec modèle dépassé ce
périple avec du tout voiture
donc la solution elle est beaucoup plus
architecturale urbanistique simplement
le petit truc on va faire une voix vélo
aussi les solutions quoi c'est air qui a
pas de solution
Alexandra là sur le périph après après
non mais non mais non moi le problème si
je suis pas représentative et j'espère
qu'aucun de mes camarades de libération
on est en train de regarder cette
émission parce que là je vais faire une
grande révélation je vais faire non j'ai
une passion pour le périphérique je
trouve qu'il y a rien de plus rom parce
que de rouler sur le périphérique la
nuit avec la musique avec la musique
parce que je ne prends jamais puisque je
n'ai pas de voiture mais mais j'aime
vraiment beaucoup le périphérique bon
mais ça c'est chacun ses névroses mais
mais
la nuit était la musique c'est le
bonheur c'est le bonheur total mais mais
simplement bon c'est vrai que c'est un
truc au niveau pollution là on atteint
des niveaux stratosphériques et je
trouve que le végétaliser une partie du
périphérique si c'était possible ce
serait super ce serait alors là ce sera
encore plus génial de rouler avec de la
musique la nuit et avec des des palmiers
tout autour enfin je caricature de ceux
qui n'ont pas de voiture absolument mais
je sais et je pense que ça va être
intéressant de toute façon ça sert à
rien de dire que va-t-on faire du
périphérique puisque ça va vraiment
dépendre de la façon dont on arrive à
désengorger Paris le centre de Paris
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire dans Paris
est-ce que ça va être réservé aux
transports en commun mais massif pour
qu'il y en ait beaucoup au taxi
électrique au covoiturage au vélo
évidemment comme ça comme c'est le donc
du coup que va devenir le périphérique
dans ce dans ce contexte là mais je
trouve que c'est bien d'ouvrir et
d'imaginer les choses même les plus
farfelues
j'aimerais bien moi aussi écrire une
nouvelle sur une histoire extraordinaire
qui se passerait sur le périph mais de
fait d'ailleurs je vais peut-être le
faire en pensant à vous mais je crois
qu'il faut voir le périphérique dans un
ensemble et pas seulement un ensemble
géographique qui est celui de Paris mais
qui est celui de l'Île-de-France le
périph s'inscrit dans l'Île-de-France de
la même façon que Paris ne vit pas ça la
vie c'est un Poubeau qui est irrigué par
l'extérieur ou un cœur qui est irrigué
ou l'inverse qui est ce qui Héric qui on
ne sait pas mais en l'occurrence
effectivement le périphérique marque une
séparation mais le périphérique est
aussi indispensable pour tous les
Franciliens qui doivent non cela qui ne
peuvent plus traverser Paris par exemple
en raison d'une politique de réduction
des voitures et dont on peut se
féliciter moi je m'en félicite avec des
enfants j'ai eu combien de bronchiolites
qu'on a supposé être causé par
le périph est indispensable pour les
habitants de la région oui et pour ceux
qui travaillent et pour ceux qui doivent
prendre leur voiture donc voilà je pense
qu'il n'y a aucune solution qui puisse
être définitif après la question de
verdir le bord du périphérique oui
absolument Anne Hidalgo là il faut le
savoir elle est en tension avec pas mal
des écologistes parce que justement son
projet n'est pas tant de verdir ou de
végétaliser distillent que de bétonner
les abords de Paris de construire de
nouveaux immeubles certes de limiter la
voiture mais de profiter de l'emprise
territoriale pour récupérer de l'argent
dont elle a évidemment besoin et donc la
question c'est est-ce que ce sera
vraiment vert ou est-ce qu'on va faire
une autre sorte de d'urbanisme qui ne
sera pas tellement plus positif
je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit George
Marc je pense que c'est un peu des
demi-mesures et que en effet si on avait
la possibilité technique par exemple de
couvrir le périph ou de faire des choses
de plus grand d'ampleur ce serait ce
serait mieux
moi j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer sur la politique je pense que
c'est la pierre-maire de toute
l'histoire de Paris et que elle a et
qu'elle a détruit à mon sens moi elle a
terriblement abîmée Paris je trouve
qu'elle a en empêchant la circulation
comme elle l'a fait en faisant du centre
une espèce de parc d'attraction pour les
touristes riches en rendant encore plus
pollué non moi je trouve que rien n'est
une bonne idée dans ce qu'elle a fait
franchement et quand transformant le
périple
finalement de transformer ce périple ce
tout bagnole
faisons des choses grandes pourquoi
faire des choses petites quand on peut
quand on peut faire des choses grandes
avec les moyens qu'on aurait si elle
dépensait bien l'argent n'importe
comment il y a beaucoup de choses à
regarder dans les finances de la de la
Mairie de Paris il y a énormément de
sujets dans les finances de la Mairie de
Paris donc voilà moi je je suis j'étais
à Marseille il y a pas très longtemps
par exemple et j'étais content de
retrouver une vraie ville à Marseille
bah oui bah c'est quand vous êtes en
voiture dans le en plein milieu de la
journée je vais vous les transports en
commun 0 je vais vous dire Marseille
normaux il y a des garages il y a des
des gens très mélangés les on a par
exemple le simple fait de fermer
certaines rues oui mais nous on en a
autour de Paris le simple fait de fermer
certaines rues comme c'est maintenant
très souvent fait pour faire quoi pour
mettre une espèce de de zone piétonne
avec un demi arbre mais on sait pas
vraiment c'est un arbre des terrasses à
des terrasses on a que ça des terrasses
congestionnent sa congestionne la ville
et ça crée cette espèce d'ambiance moi
j'ai pas envie que Paris soit réservé
aux touristes j'ai envie de parler reste
une vraie ville non les habitants s'en
vont les habitants sans vous paris est
une ville d'exode les gens les gens sont
bons de Paris et ça c'est un vrai sujet
sur la forme et une consultation qui est
consultation
en ligne qui est organisé jusque jusqu'à
la fin mai est-ce que c'est une bonne
idée de consulter les Parisiens les
habitants voilà c'est plus de démocratie
directe
d'inventer les casseroles pour Madame
Hidalgo parce que elle elle entend pas
non mais il y a des casseroles pour
Monsieur Macron
il y a quelque chose
le problème de de l'audition politique
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi il concerne
aussi madame Hidalgo elle entend rien
elle entend pas les gens elle entend pas
les protestations
en ligne
franchement les trottinettes c'était une
honte absolue de scrutin qu'elle a fait
sur les trottinettes les trottinettes
sont utilisées très majoritairement par
des gens jeunes elle a fait exprès elle
a fait exprès de faire un scrutin
physique ou il peut pas lui reprocher
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui vous pensez que les jeunes
ont que ça à faire excusez-moi d'aller
voter elle a évidemment fait ça
elle a évidemment fait ça exprès c'est
elle qui est mauvaise foi est-ce que
c'était difficile aujourd'hui
d'organiser un scrutin numérique de
voter par internet comme elle le fait là
sur le périph elle pouvait parfaitement
le faire elle l'a pas fait et d'ailleurs
elle a mis son annonce madame de Ravinel
dans le Figaro 3 jours avant le scrutin
pour être certaine de toucher les
bourgeois de l'Ouest parisien qui achète
le journal papier pour qu'il se déplace
en masse et c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé or ces fameuses trottinettes
cet escavé trouver l'initiative privée
pour survivre au cauchemar créé par
l'administration Hidalgo qui est le pari
d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est
trottinette permettent de survivre à
toutes ces à toutes ces horreurs et
d'utiliser ben non c'est non c'est mieux
c'est beaucoup plus bon on vous mettra
pas d'accord on vous mettra mais toute
façon oui mais avec les trottinettes et
je suis désolé je finis quand même par
là c'est unique au monde Paris est la
seule non mais est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on a le droit de se poser la question
Paris est la seule ville du monde qui a
interdit les trottinettes en
libre-service
comme chaque semaine on termine cette
émission par un top flogbe je vous pose
une question très simple qui a marqué
l'actualité de la semaine en bien ou en
mal Sophie vous commencez votre top et
votre flop de la semaine qu'est-ce que
c'est et bien écoutez j'ai j'ai deux
faux flops devraient flop c'est cette
histoire absolument épouvantable qui
s'est passé dans les Vosges de ce jeune
adolescent qui a tué une petite fille de
5 ans qu'on a retrouvé dans un sac dans
le domicile des parents de ce garçon et
je pense évidemment la question il a été
mis en centre pendant un an la question
c'est de savoir pourquoi est-ce que la
justice n'a pas vraiment suffisamment
bien traitée nous parlions des problèmes
de la justice tout à l'heure là c'est
clairement et bien écoutez non c'est un
TOP un top en forme de flop mais un
Marlène Schiappa le ministre qui est
absolument non seulement un des
boulonnable mais en plus inoxydable
parce que malgré toutes les accusations
portées contre elles qui sont quand même
lourdes et qui reviennent et en
particulier sur les dernières enquêtes
absolument du fond Marianne et bien non
rien du tout tout est bien et tout va
bien et ça marche donc votre top et
votre flop vous êtes venu avec un livre
je crois alors donc mon top c'est ce
livre de Britney houses qui s'appelle
les éclats qui est donc le dernier roman
de battestanellis moi j'ai toujours
beaucoup admirer cette cette écrivain et
j'ai toujours eu la surprise presque en
le lisant parce que c'est un écrivain
dont on connaît les ingrédients la
jeunesse la drogue la folie la
dépression et on on
je m'attendais presque un peu sans me
souvenir vraiment de ma surprise à
chaque fois à trouver tous ces
ingrédients dans le désordre et cela où
c'est un grand c'est qu'en fait il y a
un éclat pour le coup dans ces phrases
et
c'est un grand livre
pour noter et mon flop qui n'a rien à
voir pardon c'est le revient à des
considérations bassement prosaïques et
nationale politique c'est de d'apprendre
que le gouvernement a renoncé à sa loi
sur l'immigration non pas que je sois un
fanatique de la question de
l'immigration mais je pense que c'est
une question
importante je pense que en réalité rien
n'a été fait de substantiel sur cette
question pendant le précédent
quinquennat que ça fait pousser ce
projet de loi les extrêmes et qui
seraient quand même temps pour le coup
de se saisir de manière dépassionnée de
ce sujet important Alexandra votre top
et votre flop très rapidement s'il vous
plaît alors le top on en a parlé le
mariage pour tous sachant que quand même
cette semaine c'est formidable que ce
soit rentré comme ça dans les plus
industribles et le flop c'est Gérald
Darman pour à la fois ça s’allois
immigration qui est repoussée au
calendrier grec et son opération
wambushu cette semaine à Mayotte qui a
démarré n'importe comment et dont on
n'est pas sûr de l'utilité voilà mais
Georges Marc c'est à vous votre
monde
on les connaît pas en fait
[Musique]
et c'est oui c'est plutôt madame Ramadan
c'était un ministre de la culture qu'on
ne connaissait pas elle a eu le courage
contre le Macron bashing de prendre un
micro de répondre à la CGT et autres et
de tenir un discours que certains
députés ou certains ministres un peu
fade ne tiennent pas donc on a une mise
de la culture on a pu le constater en
tout cas au micro
c'est les dirigeants du Zénith qui ont
qui ont signé une contrat de location
j'imagine avec Dieudonné vous savez
Dieudonné et son ami complotiste antivax
Lalan le célèbre chanteur et je trouve
ça un peu minable parce que ça va donner
lieu à rassemblement de de fan de Dieu
de néon on imagine ce que c'est c'est la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
participé merci à tous les quatre un
grand salut à vous derrière votre écran
on me dit dans l'oreillette que vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux merci à
vous vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sena.fr elle est y
faire un tour ça vaut le coup on se
retrouve quant à nous la semaine
prochaine même jour même heure et même
endroit beuh
[Musique]